Emma said hey back projection cue music
and action!
Hollywood legends, Mr. Stan Laurel and Oliver Hardy arrived in Britain today as they embarked on a national tour.
We're doing this well while waiting for this new picture to come together
I'm gonna make sure that this tour gets off the right foot
There it is the
Eiffel Tower
It's amazing that you two are still going strong still using the same old material
Here they are.
Such a wonderful reception. Isn't it Eden? It's okay.
To double X for the price of one
Really empty last night, I guess if you just don't want to see Laurel and Hardy anymore
It's even pushing you a little too hard, babe
You know, Stan
You could have said goodbye Oliver a long time ago
We had a good thing going but you had this big chip on your shoulder
Cuz I did a picture with someone else I couldn't sleep the days when they told me what you did
You're just a lazy ass got who got lucky because you met me
lucky!?
to spend my life with a man who hides behind his typewriter
You betrayed me betrayed our friendship.
Your Hollow
You cannot go onstage again in your condition
I love you, but I won't stand by and watch this nutty tour or put you in a wooden box.
Should never had us take this tour. I love him Eda
You're not leaving on your Stan?
the show must go on
When you watch our movies that was just the two of us
All we had was Each other
in their regret our ears you shouldn't read reverie any
Please Gentlemen,
Mr. Stan Laurel and  Mr. Oliver Hardy
I'll miss us when we're gone. Shall we?